und aus münchen zugeschaltet ist uns
jetzt klaus holetschek es in bayern der
staatsminister für gesundheit und pflege
ich grüße sie herr check in münchen
guten morgen und christa holetschek
viele bundesländer haben probleme mit
dem nachschub beim impfen weil nicht
genügend impfdosen angekommen ist sind
wie es der bayerische weg
na ja für uns ist es natürlich auch
ärgerlich weil zuverlässigkeit und
planbarkeit ist ist in dem system
natürlich immens wichtig darauf passiert
ja auch die vereinbarkeit von
impfterminen in unseren über 100m
zentren die wir im land haben und
deswegen würden wir das wirklich
wünschen dass diese impfdosen regelmäßig
kommen und dass wir auch in der
vorausschau dass perspektivisch besser
planen können
wie ist denn das in der praxis geben sie
uns einen blick also da sind impfdosen
bestellt aber die kommen dann nicht an
und die leute sitzen da und müssen
wieder unverrichteter dinge abziehen
oder wie muss ich mir vorstellen die
praxis ist so dass der bund ja zuständig
ist für die verteilung des impfstoffs
das geschieht nach einer bestimmten
bevölkerungsschutz
wir bekommen dann diese impfdosen wir
verteilen sie dann an unsere impfzentren
die dann tatsächlich mit der impfung
beginnen erst mal in den alten und
pflegeheimen das ist der schwerpunkt
jetzt aber natürlich werden auch schon
termine in den impfzentren vereinbart
zum beispiel an die gruppe der über 80
jährigen und die muss man natürlich vor
planen und dann muss man natürlich auch
halten können und das kannst du
natürlich nur wenn genügend impfstoff da
ist und das war erst vor kurzem passiert
ist war natürlich extrem schwierig dass
wir da sehr kurzfristig erfahren haben
dass impfstofflieferungen ausfallen und
dann auch sehr spät wie viel denn
überhaupt wirklich kommen
es war ein völliges durcheinander und
sie haben so reagiert dass sie gesagt
haben okay wir gehen jetzt an die
eiserne reserve die wir uns eigentlich
zurückhalten wollen und spritzen quasi
alles weg was wir haben
wir haben natürlich eine kluge logistik
wir haben stand heute 260.000 menschen
in bayern geimpft davon über 16.000
zweit impfungen schon und das ist ja
ganz wichtig die zweite umfahren müssen
ja in einem bestimmten abstand erfolgen
also die wollen wir auf jeden fall
halten wir wollen aber möglichst schnell
auch wieder erst impfungen durchführen
weil das natürlich ein stück weit das
licht am ende des tunnels ist gerade in
den alten und pflegeheimen wo die
ausbruchsgeschehen hoch sind müssen wir
impfen und deswegen versuchen wir das
natürlich immer logistisch klug aus zu
steuern
die zweitimpfung zu garantieren aber
auch möglichst schnell wieder mit erste
impfungen nachzusteuern
wir haben jetzt zwei impfstoffe wir
haben bei antec wir haben moderner und
ich hoffe dass auch astrazeneca sehr
schnell zugelassen wird dann wird es
auch leichter in die hausarztpraxen zu
gehen und die ärzte mit einzubinden
wie machen sie das auch in der praxis
rufen sie auch vielleicht in anderen
bundesländern an nach motto habt ihr
noch ein paar wir brauchen jetzt sage
ich mal 12.000 für das frankenland oder
so nein das machen wir nicht
bayern hat er zurzeit auch den vorsitz
in der gesundheitsministerkonferenz wir
sind den regelmäßigen austausch jede
woche und die kolleginnen und kollegen
suchen natürlich auch nach den
möglichkeiten ihre menschen vor ort zu
impfen
deswegen wollen wir dass das system
insgesamt funktioniert angefangen von
der europäischen union über den bund bis
zu uns das erwarten die menschen auch
draußen
es gibt einfach verärgerung wir müssen
zuverlässiger werden weil die menschen
haben jetzt eine hohe impfbereitschaft
und impfen kann ich nur wenn ich den
impfstoff habe wenn jetzt sie oder den
arzt der spritzen möchte ein patient
angeht oder einzuimpfen
und sagt wieso kommt das nicht wie
erklären sie es den menschen
naja man muss schon auch sagen dass
natürlich die produktion und auch bis
zur zulassung des impfstoffs das
wirklich sehr schnell gegangen ist wir
dürfen ja nicht vergessen es ist jetzt
dann ein jahr
das würde coroner reden die ersten
ausbrüche damals bei webasto wenn man
das jetzt in der zeitachse sieht dann
sind wir froh dass wir erst mal
überhaupt impfstoff haben
das ist die gute botschaft das gehört
auch zur wahrheit dazu dass jetzt die
produktion noch rutschig und hatte das
ist vielleicht auch die ihm geschuldet
dass wir einfach am anfang nicht gewusst
hat welcher impfstoff ist der erste was
kommt denn am anfang aber wir müssen
jetzt dringend schauen dass wir mehr
kriegen und dass wir dann sehr schnell
auch impfen können weil das ist
tatsächlich im moment das mittel der
ersten wahl in der bekämpfung der
pandemie auch wieder den praktiker
gefragt wie viel tage davor erfahren sie
auch als minister wie viel impfungen
kommen werden und wie sicher sind dann
diese zu sagen also beim letzten mal war
es ja kurzfristig da haben wir am
freitag erfahren dass die lieferungen
ausgesetzt werden oder nicht in der
größe kommen
und haben wir am montag drauf am
nachmittag am späten nachmittag erst
erfahren in welcher höhe denn die
lieferungen nicht kommen
das war jetzt schon ein extremfall das
hoffe ich wird nicht mehr sein
das haben wir auch deutlich gemacht wir
sitzen alle in einem boot das nützt
nichts jetzt irgendwie schuldzuweisungen
zu machen die menschen erwarten von uns
dass das system funktioniert und dafür
müssen wir sorgen und das müssen wir
gemeinsam mit den unternehmern mit dem
bund mit eu bis runter zu den kommunen
und ich hoffe dass wir jetzt die
nächsten drei vier wochen die zahlen die
wir jetzt bekommen haben dass die auch
zu treffen und mit denen planen wir
momentan wie sieht es denn aus wenn sie
mit den ministerkollegen in anderen
bundesländer entsprechend steht dabei
noch vergleichsweise gut da oder ist es
genauso schlecht wie in anderen
bundesländern
also wir führen ja keinen wettbewerb
davon halte ich ehrlich gesagt auch
nichts dass wir jeden tag in irgendeiner
bundesliga tabelle ist sozusagen in
anführungszeichen schauen und wer vorne
ist und wir hinten
es geht einfach darum dass wir unseren
menschen in unseren bundesländern ein
ins angebot machen das möglichst schnell
und möglichst gut und das wollen wir
alle alle länder wollen da an einem
strang ziehen und möglichst schnell
impfen dazu brauchen wir ich kann es nur
noch mal sagen den impfstoff da sind wir
nicht herr des verfahrens das will ich
deutlich sagen sondern wir sind darauf
angewiesen dass das was vereinbart war
europäische union bund besorgt den
impfstoff wir kämpfen dass das
eingehalten wird und dass diese kette
einwandfrei funktioniert wenn sie sich
was wünschen dürfen heute ist letzter
tag der woche was würden sie sich
wünschen
ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
möglichst bald wieder ein stück
normalität im leben für die menschen
erreichen können dass viele sich impfen
lassen nicht weil es eben es gibt ja
keine impfpflicht sondern die impfung
ist freiwillig aber dass wir gemeinsam
als gesellschaft gut durch diese
pandemie rdx steuern dass wir uns jetzt
an die regeln halten
aber dann auch licht am ende des tunnels
sehen und das wünsche ich mir von herzen
dann wünsche ich ihnen das auch klaus
holetschek von der csu war dass der
bayerische staatsminister für gesundheit
und pflege in einem guten tag in münchen
dankeschön vielen dank